[Música]
aquí en este espacio oscuro consolidó a
curso interespacial en este espacio solo
sin luz un lugar donde parece no habita
la vida
inicia la resiliencia
inicia la lucha por tener un espacio en
el planeta tierra
aquí las almas comienzan a tomar forma y
vida en su sangre se incrusta en códigos
genéticos históricos culturales de vidas
pasadas se da luz a una nueva vida nueva
sangre y esperanza para el mundo
hola
muy buenas noches a todos mi nombre es
tarot gonzález soy pues un vividor
porque me encanta vivir la vida soy un
fotógrafo loco que pues que le gusta
viajar por pues por todo méxico por el
mundo y también al interior de mi ser no
que creo que ese es el viaje más hermoso
que he encontrado bien y en esos viajes
encontré encontré a un chico muy lindo
un niño un niño que me contó una gran
historia muy bonita
y ese niño es el niño sangre de perro
este niño sangre de perro me platicó un
poquito que viajara a conocer a mi niño
a mi niño interior en mis viajes he
viajado por ocho países gracias a dios y
al trabajo que tengo y con una cámara
con una cámara gracias a esa cámara y
por la lente logró captar este tipo de
imágenes cuando voy a viajar este
trabajo no lo vendes es un trabajo
personal que me gusta son documentos que
yo guardo para contarle la historia a mi
pequeño que está ahí enfrente para
contarle la historia de mi vida esta
imagen la tomé en israel en un barrio
ortodoxo en un barrio donde no te
permiten tomar fotografías la luz de
atrás era muy hermosa el niño venía
corriendo solamente seguí mi instinto sé
que la cámara no va a grabar pero me
agaché tomé mi cámara me puse al nivel
del niño y salió esa hermosa fotografía
yo le pude haber 15 días después pensé
que no había logrado capturar y pongo la
imagen de este niño porque el niño
sangre de perro me contó me contó esto
no
en israel este niño tiene una educación
cristiana y en otro viaje me fui a
belice me fui a belice a seguir
conociendo a seguir conociendo me y este
este niño esta hermosa sonrisa esta alma
pura su educación es en la selva a su
educación él no conoce el cristianismo
pero si conoce el él la vida conocer las
plantas conoce las plantas de poder
conocer los restos y conoce esa hermosa
sonrisa que te da el caminar por los
ríos y por la naturaleza y ver las
montañas y las nubes y después en un
encuentro también con este niño sangre
de perro me contó y me dijo que tenía
que viajar a este lugar a jesús maría
jesús maría la sierra de aquí de nayarit
en esta tierra pues están los ancestros
del niño sangre de perro ahí está ahí
nace después toda su sangre no esos
abuelos a las historias de su madre
cuando cruzaba el río entonces este niño
sangre de perro me decía que en su
búsqueda
él quería conocer qué pasaba con él no
que pasaba por con sus emociones con el
color de su piel porque él todo lo
quería ser corriendo porque le gustaba
pintarse porque le gustaban las plantas
nadar por el río entonces él me
compartió todo esto y yo le pregunté
seguramente igual que ustedes tienen esa
duda no porque sangre de perro y yo le
decía por qué te dices llamar niño
sangre de perro y creo que me lo contó
en es muy bonito
el niño sangre de perro me comentaba que
pues él se auto domina zanjeros de perro
por el lugar de nacimiento no este niño
nace aquí en esta tierra que seguramente
todos la conocen se llama santiago
ixcuintla nayarit y ese santiago
ixcuintla es aquí esta tierra hermosa
santiago escuintla santiago es por el
apóstol y cuando los cristianos vienen y
dominan a los pueblos indígenas
con punta de espada y sangre y en el
nombre de dios y escuintla es el lugar
donde nacen los perros donde nacemos los
perros los sangre de perros es un lugar
donde recuerdo que había mucha esperanza
y sigue habiendo mucha esperanza donde
las campanas suenan donde las campanas
suenan y nosotros acudíamos ahí y las
historias de los abuelos y las abuelas
nos platicaban de lo hermoso que es la
unidad la unidad de los pueblos la
unidad de la gente y los corazones en el
resto y así iniciaba el cristianismo en
la vida del niño sangre de perro y este
cristianismo también le metí a ésta en
este misticismo pues ahí en santiago
está esta isla que seguramente muchos de
aquí conocemos y los que están en el td
extiendo pues seguramente querrán
conocer aquí en nayarit es la cuna de la
mexicanidad donde parten los primeros
pobladores de la gran tenochtitlán esta
hermosa isla que se ven las fotografías
y este niño sangre de perro dice que un
día fue y la vio y también vio una foto
pues una foto aérea era muy parecida a
estos estos señores mexicas que pues que
habían fundado la gran tenochtitlán que
es
la raíz de todos los mexicanos y este
niño también como vieron en el vídeo se
empezaron a incrustar en sus genes y en
su código genética pues todo este sabor
no el tejuino los nancys el este que que
te lo preparan con un limoncito bien
rico los camarones el zarandeado y tito
de esta este bagaje de toda esta esta
riqueza
gastronómica que tenemos aquí en el
estado y también este este el niño
sangre de perro me contó mucho esta
historia que cuando él estaba en tepic
bay en su escudo un hombre moreno grande
fuerte con el pelo largo entonces este
niño me decía que pues desde el inj él
veía que los hombres eran de pelo largo
fuertes grandes estos guerreros a este
señor el rey nayar considerado un dios
para el pueblo coral para todo éste
señor guerrero le peleaba y luchó por su
pueblo hoy nuestras nuestras raíces se
conservan nuestra tradición se conserva
gracias a estos guerreros que luchaban
con amor y con alegría por las familias
por los pueblos
y con ese amor esos guerreros gracias a
ellos hoy lo que nosotros somos como
nayaritas que nayarit significa hijo que
está en la en la tierra y en el sol
somos esos hijos de dios estamos en una
tierra sagrada y con todo ese bagaje el
niño sangre de perro tuvo miedo mucho
miedo a su nombre el niño sangre de
perro se llamaba jesús un hombre muy
poderoso un hombre que es muy fuerte
cargarlo por la pureza que tiene él
mismo no y por lo que representa
entonces con él con toda esta con toda
esta historia que les cuento el niño
sangre de perro santiaguense con todo lo
que les platico sale sale de este mundo
y se va a buscar un sueño se va a buscar
un sueño y conoce una cámara y a través
de la cámara empieza a contar esta
historia de coraje de discriminación por
no tener estudios pues no tener una
escuela por ser moreno por muchas cosas
no por ser un indio
entonces pues este extranjera de perro
se va y cree en él cree en las luchas
sociales conoce el zapatismo en nayarit
en bellavista que es donde estalló la
primera huelga entonces sigue con estos
movimientos sociales registrado hace un
documental para ciudad juárez como ve
como están matando a las mujeres de cómo
están asesinando a las mujeres
y si quiere registrarlo y su corazón
late y le dice que tiene que ir a ya a
documentar eso y el niño sangre de perro
se vuelve un documentalista de cosas de
la vida de injusticias y de temas que le
duelen en su corazón para trascender y
gracias a ese a ese sueño ya esas ganas
el niño sangre de perro pues convierte
todo todo todo es todas esas historias
que va recogiendo con su cámara las
traduce en una empresa y dios y la vida
lo pone en un lugar muy privilegiado con
trabajo y mucho esfuerzo la vida lo
lleva a trabajar en grandes empresas a
conocer cómo los grandes emporios y las
modelos y las edecanes son maquilladas
por el medio digital que nosotros
aprendimos que la belleza se compra
y muy barata se compra muy barata pero
por mucho dinero y eso hace la
publicidad de la mercadotecnia seguirnos
engañándose a nosotros mismos y el niño
sangre de perro cayó en esa en esa
trampa
el niño cárcel sangre de perro se olvidó
de sus raíces el niño sangre de perro le
gustó el dinero el niño sangre de perro
le gustó el poder y se enfermó el niño
sangre de perro tiene una enfermedad que
se llama al vitíligo y es una enfermedad
meramente estética que te cambia la piel
no sé si lo han visto que eres moreno y
luego se te cambia para blanco no y esta
es esta enfermedad lo hizo mucho
reflexionar porque si ustedes lean de la
enfermedad del vitíligo es la pérdida de
nuestra identidad
el niño sangre de perro se estaba
convirtiendo y no es en el sentido de la
palabra en el hombre blanco me estaba
convirtiendo en blanco y no digo que el
hombre blanco sea malvado las almas de
los seres humanos somos malvados en el
color de piel entonces en esta pérdida
de identidad también él
necesita una búsqueda interna que es ahí
donde está la resiliencia o donde el
niño sangre de perro encuentra la
resiliencia porque el niño sangre de
perro está rodeado de muchas personas
que dicen quererle amarle estar con él
porque ahora gana dinero ya no es
ni feo ahora es un ser guapo bonito que
sirve económicamente a muchas personas
ya un sistema que lo necesitaba para
cumplir objetivos pero esos objetivos no
eran los del corazón del niño sangre de
perro y se da cuenta de esa enfermedad y
se va a curar él está buscando una
curación para su corazón y lo quiso
buscar en las medicinas tradicionales y
no había nada que lo curará él seguía
enfermo de su corazón y de su mente de
su palabra
y en esa búsqueda
en esa búsqueda el niño sangre de perro
llega llorando con unas con unas señoras
que les llaman abuelas
y el niño sangre de perro recuerda mucho
a su abuela su abuela silvestre una
parte de la cola
esta parte de la cuerda que trae a la
vida y que nos platicaba y lanzaba y la
dejaba muy bonito con su con su canto y
el niño sangre de perro no respetaba esa
autoridad de la abuela ese gran
conocimiento que tenía de los ancestros
que no eran su conocimiento en el
conocimiento de los abuelos de sus
abuelos y de muchas personas de la
comunidad que les gustaba transmitirlo y
este niño sangre de perro una vez tiene
una gran ceremonia muy fuerte con
plantas de poder y se acerca un hombre
al
de pelo largo flaco un hombre muy
hermoso
y el niño sangre de perro le dice que
estaba cansado de trabajar de trabajar
para el gobierno porque el niño sangre
de perro tuvo una gran expertise y los
señores de gobiernos los control
contrataban porque él conocía las
problemáticas sociales y las y las
operaba y él y este hombre le dice el
niño sangre de perro no tengas miedo
carnal no temas toma tu fuerza en los
gobiernos y en las sociedades
necesitamos indios fuertes que tomen las
armas que tomen su fuerza y su corazón y
luchen por su gente que tomen buenas
decisiones que acaben con la corrupción
que acaben con la mala palabra y el mal
pensamiento que no tengas miedo a bailar
a danzar a vivir
y le dijo y le contó la historia del
escarabajo mierdero esos escarabajos que
hacen bolitas
hacen bolitas y las acomodan
perfectamente y se ve espectacular
también una toma es una imagen muy
bonita y así me decía si tú andas entre
la e
sé como un escarabajo acomoda la enseña
de acomodarla y tu mantente limpio y
tornasol mantén tu pureza porque si es
posible y este camino eso me ha enseñado
el niño sangre de perro vino a su pueblo
a jesús maría a lanzarle al sol ya
entender
a qué le danzaban sus abuelos ya que le
cantaban sus abuelos
el niño sangre de perro regreso a
conocer a sus ancestros regreso a
conocer su tierra con la cual estaba
peleada
qué es esta tierra hermosa que me
reencuentro y amo con todo mi corazón
el niño sangre de perro regresa de
brasil
regresa de brasil entendiendo hace un
mes y este año gracias a dios me tocó
esta charla y compartirla con ustedes
después de seis años de no haber tenido
necesidad económica de nada y de estar
para aparentemente en la cima de una
empresa y de todo lo que socialmente la
gente piensa que es bello y lindo y por
lo que luchamos el niño sangre de perro
se dio cuenta que pues eso era la caja
en la que vivimos y nos mantiene el
sistema pensando que tenemos que vivir y
trabajar por el dinero olvidándonos del
tiempo de los hijos de los tíos hermosos
fotógrafos de las primas de las mamás y
de los amigos y de la tierra por la que
tenemos que luchar y defender y en
brasil me mostraron los mares los lagos
me enseñaron a rezar con ellos me
enseñaron a rezar con los pájaros con
las lagunas con las cascadas y me di
cuenta cuán rica es nuestra tierra cuán
rica es nuestra cultura cuán ricos son
nuestros colores y nuestras formas de
vivir cuán ricas son nuestros abuelos
que nos
señán avanzar a bailar a sentir el
corazón y a tocarnos a tocarnos las
almas y realmente defender nayarit y
este hombre que decía yo conocí a estas
bellas mujeres que son unas nanas que
transforman vidas que entregan sus
cuerpos al resto y a la naturaleza que
es es dios el es dios y nosotros todos
nosotros ustedes vivimos en una tierra
hermosa y sagrada que se llama nayarit y
que esa tierra vemos muchos que estamos
afuera tratando de representarla con el
corazón con la sangre que estamos
cansados de salir de nuestra tierra hace
rato una charla decían que cuando sales
de tu tierra te vuelves vulnerable muy
vulnerable y eres un guerrero solo que
cuando regresas y ves a tu manada
se siente un gran una gran emoción
[Aplausos]
y con ellos aprendí la umh el amor la
unión y el entendimiento de mi ser que
para conectar con muchas cosas laborales
y del mundo y poder entender esta cosa
que llaman éxito y poderla dominar y
poder dominar la mente el cuerpo y el
corazón para la toma de decisiones
importantes en la vida de esas personas
que quieren ser empresarios políticos
que quieren tomar el poder por el poder
que esas personas que toman decisiones
por todos nosotros
que por lo menos tomen conciencia
primero de su ser antes de tomar
conciencia de todos antes de tomar
decisiones por todos nosotros
necesitamos sanar nuestras almas y
nuestros corazones y conectarnos con
nuestra familia nuestra raíz nuestra
madre nuestro padre y el respeto
a ellos que la madre es la madre tierra
y así respetas a tu madre y así la madre
universal y el padre universal que nos
dio la vida y eso es el agradecimiento
que nos enseñan nuestros ancestros estos
señores tejedores
de camisas de comida y de restos que
llevan al universo
y
así es la sangre de perro los perros son
nobles y a pesar de los golpes y heridas
provocadas en el camino no dejan de ser
fieles y de sonreír de mover la cola
hasta que sienten malicia son fieras que
defienden y defenderán a la manada
y mi frase resiliente con la que quiero
cerrar
que desde estas hermosas damas que
caminan y guían un poquito mi
pensamiento y mis acciones que dice que
todo lo que camines en esta vida ayude a
otros seres y esa es la frase que a mí
me motiva a seguir caminando y viviendo
que cada cosa que haga tiene que ayudar
a otro
y si puede ser económico pero también
emocional una palabra una escucha un
abrazo
les agradezco mucho yo soy jesús
francisco gonzález estrada el niño
sangre de perro y que todo lo que
caminan en esta vida ayude a otros seres
gracias manada coral
[Aplausos]
[Música]